so it's become an annual experience for
us we closed thinking digital with a
talk from Tom Scott and every year he
manages to find an even crazier and
whackier way to surprise us and delight
us and this year he is actually going to
be joining us via a live link Tom can
you hear me Tom yes I'm here hello hello
thinking good show okay either my
earpiece is not working or you guys are
really quite how long thinking digital
right I've had to step outside to do
this talk today I do hope you don't mind
it's just that the social health and
safety team quite understandably would
not let me do this talk indoors I will
get to one that is in a couple of
minutes but first a little bit
background I don't like having stuff I
don't like accumulating physical things
stuff builds up stuff is something you
have to deal with to tidy to dust to lug
around with you that you really have to
move on
ideally I'll be able to fit my life into
a suitcase on the other hand I hoard
data my email archive goes back to 1999
that being the year when I learned how
important backups are I have a partner
of nearly everything digital if I ever
made since then but then digital data is
a lot easier to preserve it takes up no
great amount of space um you can make
backup copies in a second all my data is
safe in multiple absolute last resort
there's a 60 gigabyte file setting on
Amazon glacier in case someone hits
London wouldn't electromagnetic pulse
bomb this meanwhile is my clinic it is a
jerseys activewear super sweats hoodie
code for 997 and large in a color called
oxford gray it is incredibly comfortable
but that's because I found it for 10
years and worn it for all of those 10 it
was given to me on the 21st of October
2002 are the word in front Nordics
refers to the north dickinson counter
school I was in felt
that's not a joke it actually is the
name of the town when I was 17 I spent
six months touring around small-town
America and I spent a day at North
Dickinson County school where among
other things a much Gorka version of me
are you cute following a much clearer
version of me did an ask a British guy
session and afterwards the the person
was showing me round presented me with
this Nordics hoodie
I never realized quite how much
sentimental value
I was attaching to this honey but this
hoodie has has been following me around
for ten years it's become associated
with Who I am
to the extent that I somehow looked a
little bit wrong in pictures were I'm
wearing something else um if you've been
at this conference in past years you'll
have seen me in this hoodie it was with
me when I went around Australia awful
University on a submarine in San
Francisco it was duct taped to a
shipping container with me to see if I
could walk like Spiner
I couldn't um it was with me when I
toured Bletchley Park catching beads at
Mardi Gras I'm standing on the gunnels
of a canal boat in an gone with nothing
between me and a 200-foot drop it was
with me when I moved to London when I
took a trip to some abandoned c4
throughout all the time I was filming a
TV show last year what you saw there
hopefully hopefully what you saw that
was the last 10 years of my life summed
up in a few photos um this hoodie is the
only physical thing I have that connects
me to that gorky 17 year old I'm sure
there are a few things in storage of my
parents house you probably find that
Dolphin shirt I was wearing if if you're
looking for it but they've not been
continuously with me
nothing has nothing at all there is no
other thing I own that links me to that
kid from 10 years they don't make these
hoodies anymore by the way they haven't
done for years and there is a reasonable
chance that this Nordics hoodie is the
very last one in existence the trouble
is it is too tattered and worn to wear
anymore
I was probably to tastin born years ago
like I held out desperately for as long
as I possibly could it's beyond
reasonable repair it's been patched up
so many times now
every single bit of stitches coming
apart the letters of warning faded so
much that it basically just says no
roids here now the lining is so thin
after ten years under it I can't throw
it away I realized this I can't throw it
away it's got too much sentimental value
attached to it it it can't be too hard
extending have been somewhere it's too
tattered to be donated and well
technically it could be shredded and
converted into wiping cloths by some
textile recycling company that doesn't
really sit right with me either the name
of this conference is thinking digital
and I realized that I really do think
that way um if this was digital data I
could compress it and archive it and
look back every now and then when the
mood took me but it isn't there is no
Tron style digitization rate but that
means I can keep this without also
having to store it and keep it around or
after just turning to self so this talk
is my digitization right um the story
that I've told here the pictures I've
shown the the emotion behind it is being
backed up as well as I possibly can on
its camera um I'll put this online it
won't matter if anyone watches it
because the story has been told I can
look back I can remember why this this
thing was was really important to me
without having to keep a a busted and
broken physical object around just with
some sentimental this thing here this
will become hoodie dot mp4 and it will
keep exactly as it is it forbid as long
as I keep my backups up-to-date so one
question remains now I have uploaded my
hoodie what do I do with the body um
this isn't a destructive upload I didn't
have to slice it apart to index it and
now I have transferred its digital um
there is still this apparently precious
physical object hanging around
now I know you're thinking this is
actually colored water and that there's
some pleather camera trickery going on
here it isn't and there isn't but this
is very much a test for me it is until
we got to here to this place until I had
a can of paraffin in my hand I didn't
know whether I'd actually go through
with this I didn't know if I really
could believe that I could upload my
hoodie to a video file and then the
original this precious original would
matter anymore the stories we tell the
things that we do and the memories that
we have either in our heads or in our
online backups they are more important
any physical this is why I'm here this
is why this hoodie will be all of ashes
shortly and that is why this conference
are it's called thinking digital um
thank you very much I've been Tom Scott
good night
you